Speaker 1: All right.
Let's start with something positive, we have
genuinely better and better looking COVID
updates over the last few weeks globally and
in the United States, and today is no exception.
Questions we're asking right now before we
look at the data.
Is this the last wave?
We don't know.
What will the winter look like?
We're not yet sure.
How much more do we need to vaccinate?
Quite a bit, but we're not totally sure.
Many other questions as well.
Let's start with cases since the daily Delta
variant peak of about one hundred and 67000
cases per day.
The United States is now down 39 percent in
daily average cases to about one hundred and
2000 per day outrageously high.
But as more and more people get vaccinated,
cases will mean less and less.
Dr. Isaac Bogoch last week told us, but we're
not there yet.
And for now, 39 percent daily case reduction
is a very good thing in terms of deaths in
general.
You know this by now, rule of thumb deaths
follow cases by three to four weeks.
Deaths are continuing to do so.
Deaths now down about 20 percent per day from
their Delta peak.
The Delta Peak was about 9500 deaths per day.
We're now down to about 6500 deaths per day.
Still a really high number.
Remember that a typical flu season is about
36000 deaths a year.
That's like 100 deaths a day.
So right now, we're at 16 times a typical
flu seasons, daily deaths 16 times.
That's an interesting metric, by the way,
to compare when we think about the relative
risk of death from COVID when we're out there.
How does this compare to a flu season over
the course of a year?
And the truth is, it's not really like this
because you're 36000 flu deaths are concentrated
during flu season.
That's why we call it flu season.
But on average, 100 flu deaths a day is what
the U.S. sees in a year.
We're now at 6500 COVID deaths per day.
Globally, we are seeing cases continuing down
about 35 percent since the Delta Peak.
And then, of course, global deaths as well
have peaked at about ten thousand three hundred
a day.
Those are now down to about 7000 global deaths
That's a reduction of about a third, 31 percent
to be exact in daily global deaths.
So that's good.
Now how about vaccination?
Well, as we talked about last week or the
week before, the U.S. is getting embarrassed.
The U.S. is rapidly declining in terms of
the percentage of people vaccinated in the
U.S. compared to other countries, particularly
compared to other so-called rich countries.
Take a look at this.
The leaders in vaccinated percentage are the
United Arab Emirates tiny country, followed
by Portugal, which has 10 million people Chile,
Spain, Singapore, Uruguay, Canada, Denmark,
China, Ireland, Italy, Finland, France, Japan,
U.K., Brazil, Germany.
Then you get to the United States in vaccinated
percentage just ahead of Turkey.
And just ahead of Mexico.
What happened to us?
We had all the vaccines earlier than anyone,
and we just can't do it.
People aren't getting the vaccine.
It's horrifying what's going on.
It's embarrassing what's going on, and we've
talked about it so much.
And then lastly, the global vaccination effort
overall has also slowed down.
Globally, we had gotten up to about 45 million
vaccines per day around the world.
We're now down to roughly half of that, about
23 million vaccine doses per day.
If you look at the global population, that
means each day we're vaccinating 0.2 nine
percent of the global population call it zero
point three.
Just under a third of one percent of the world
is getting a dose each day, getting that back
up to 45 million doses a day.
Even 50 60 million doses a day would be absolutely
huge.
But the good news?
No thanks to the deniers.
No thanks to the anti-vaxxers and those spreading
the disinformation and misinformation cases
down significantly.
Deaths also down.
Let's hope it continues.
We'll check in next week and hope that the
numbers are looking
even better.